laisse moi te chanter bienvenue à tous
dans cette nouvelle vidéo le saviez la
vidéo la plus vue de ma chaîne hors
musique est une vidéo en outre les
objets what the fuck japonais tous les
trois ça va ça va la dernière fois vous
n'aviez pas aimer les les intros on est
trop énergique mais en même temps mais
trop contents de se retrouver parce que
écoutez c'est comme des gamins en fait
vous savez il ya un truc alors je peux
me permettre le garage et mentale a
parlé dans un film vous avez marqué
l'endorphine que ça génère par exemple
quand on est gamin est ce que vous avez
remarqué on voit tout le temps de l'eau
comme des oufs 50 ou non mais c'est vrai
savoir si messi que tu as fait du sport
et tout à côté là les gars j'ai fait six
magasins différents pour essayer de
choper des objets amusants pour nous
puisque tu es content de ce que tu as
obtenu je suis hyper content mais c'est
un peu différentes habitudes à des trucs
vraiment maroc etc mais aussi des trucs
qui sont la wac mais très stylée pour
sonner comme le baseball qu'on avait
faits qui était l'un des meilleurs
moments de ma vie
il y aura pas d artifice dans cette
vidéo
parce que c'était un humaniste et effet
un tape dessus exhaler quand même
beaucoup mieux j'ai vu d'opci maintenant
je pète plus honnête mais les gars allez
là c'est le début de cette vidéo
allez allez tu comprendras tu y arrives
tu vas y arriver
pjanic oui c'est bien toutes ces heures
de travail c'est pas pour rien c'est pas
pour rien ça fait longtemps qu'on ne
s'était pas vue sur cette chaîne et
loulou quel plaisir n'est pas sûr de moi
et lui mis sur la gueule il avait été
lors dit mais qu'est ce mec c'est pas
l'avoir entièrement vois le mec me vise
avec un look à attiser bon mais je vais
dégager championnat mais c'est
incroyable ce jet de réguler
il ya chez eux une petite tradition dans
ses mines et aulas c'est la petite fée
rude pour toi
[Musique]
avec les traditions
après plein de petits jeux et vous allez
voir une bombe je sais que vous êtes mon
dieu je vous ai tiré alors moi il ya
même plus d'efforts c'est à dire quand
même plus de faux poil c'est du pur
plastique met toi bien peu de gens
auraient tout à fait bien plaisir au
moins au-dessus à l'e3 il ya un truc
écrite mais il faut que tu arrives à
faire ça c'est un jeu qui est très
content et je verrais tu es le premier à
essayer en nombre d'hypothèses et sont
sa phase des piles d'études passe comme
ça des petits sont réguliers les attends
moi je vais entendre trois attaques
d'affilée pad mois d'affilée
rfid et vous voulez plaire mcfly
cailleteau vouloir acheter un slip
vraiment ça leur fait un plaisir fou
[Musique]
des vidéos qui ne nécessite aucune
activité cérébrale mais le champion et
regardez moi j'ai fait en régie les
meilleurs que les japonais jcr fou c'est
jacques efforts dans tous les cas j'ai
envie de dire bravo a besoin de vous
j'ai déjà besoin de faire un tournoi de
ce jeu c'est le script z chacun notre
tour on va s'affronter en inversant le
gagnant du tournoi à un cadeau de ma
part c'est pas une blague
le gagnant du nord moi un vrai cadeau
coule vraiment un gars 2 cuil alors
chacun mais le slip bien sur la tête mon
fils bien tel homme honnête
ce sont les influenceurs et l'arbitré
dire à trois 2 1 go et à son goût le but
c'est d'être le dernier avec un slip sur
la tête
oui d'enlever le slip de l'autunois la
salle gantois que neymar lucas dans le
4e set on ne connaît pas le principe des
zones noires mais bien deux soutenues
alors si tu barras et a gagné dans ma
roue ça ok les gars vous êtes prêt
deuxième manche du tournoi 3 2 à satan
c'est cuba 3 o bravo ton cadeau c'est un
gars de chez apple mais que les gens
vont et ému christophe régate chapeaute
de tokyo avec dedans un petit
porte-clefs je suis content j'ai vu que
tu ouvrais sa défense talon c'est ma
réaction
c'est super ok j'ai un cadeau même pour
toi qui es femmes
j'adore quand ça message est un cadeau
très stylé et lui moyens etc c'est le
meilleur moment
j'ai réussi son coup je me suis
maintenant medidas pas grave mais
possible c'est quoi ces machines
baguette être coincé dans un parti dans
les gares nouvelles objet au oui bien
sûr mon droit le but du jeu est simple
et amis à tour de rôle nous avons toutes
petites roulettes et nous voyons combien
de fois on doit tirer sur son doigt
celui qui fait exploser le cul cul du
singe perdre la case oui un petit
chiffre zéro quel bonheur fait pas le
bonheur de se retrouver les gars 0 bon
bah c'est mr cette vidéo allait bien
avec m 3 allez aujourd'hui à trois fois
sur le doigt une fois le cube on
attendait c'était bien je de leur vie il
a suffit de dire le cubain
[Musique]
[Rires]
tout ça pour ça
jamais autant de gens en même temps en
france mon souffle et du n'est jamais
réaction d'un viewer 2 s'y colle en
suède ça joue jusqu'à cannes va vraiment
avoir abouti
j'attendais n'ya rien
wen alors mon visage il est normal avoir
changé son visage ça ne fait pas ton
fils
[Musique]
hu man et là haut
louis [ __ ] lui ne la gagne regardez je
fais partie d'un gang regarde ta vie tu
sais pas qui va activer ce à quoi je
l'achetais mais je me suis dit ça va
être drôle de voir ça avec aller fallait
mettre du feu sur le bus si c'est la
meilleure sauce il ya d un peu des
businessman business woman importé ça
les gamins vont kiffer sauf deux alors
non mais en compte à rebours des comptes
imaginez rô le des ou non trois ans de
cachot
c'est la meilleure chose que je commence
comme un calque à 0 sur un objet en
plastique il peut briser immédiatement
ici c'est la pichenette général c'est
vraiment on triche riche mais c'est la
pichenette suis trop contente de jouer
la piche n'amèneront ckoi oued ont
classé la pichenette puisqu'elle savait
pas s'ils tolèrent tous deux commencent
qui commence mais pour quoi faire
[Musique]
puis ce n'est de l'oreille warp et si
mal
s'il a pris en a des choses j'ai pris en
majeurs auxquels doit lucas va-t-il
opter mais moi les gars ça on est sur un
nuage
on va jouer par terre et on va dessiner
un cerf et comme les sumos le premier
qui fait sortir l'autre du cercle on
gagne le match en trois points le
premier qui tombent ou tisseur du cercle
a perdu ou qui abandonne si on respecte
les traditions des tournoi d'arts
martiaux de manga ouai 0 1 0 avaient
tapé technique de la technique de dos le
mec est plus fort non mais dont la vie
est plus tactique mais pas du tout mais
c'est incroyable y en a juste que plus
l'eau monte les marches pour la vie
[Musique]
c'est génial bel hommage
messieurs dames rhys millen gros coup
ses cinq combats mesdames et messieurs
c'est génial je suis heureux venez on
loue le sont les mêmes qu est ce que
vous avez dit bourse et j'adore je suis
fan oh je suis imbattable à la toupie
coeur là je suis en choeur douce et le
cndd jeux ou les taupes sorte à tour de
rôle vous pouvez les taper avec le
marteau pour savoir qui gagne c'est très
simple pour commencer le jeu faut mettre
ça tout à gauche vous montre ça joue
quand ça ça arrive à droite
le jeu s'arrête plus vous tapez sur des
tops moins vite il va vers la pièta il
verra s'ouvrir encore m chacun votre
tour vous allez taper sur les tops parce
que pour dire on va taupe et du coup je
vais vous chronométré le gagnant du
tournoi celui qui fait le plus petit
temps le plus longtemps parent porte un
vrai objet trop cool man vraiment moi
l'album je joue aussi qu'ils commencent
à chauffer mais pas encore de mettre à
savoir qui gagne il sait donc comment ça
vous je m'échappe sur démarrer
quinze secondes 0 chap
qu'est ce que j'aurais pas le cadeau
était prêt à non non non mais c'est pas
beau mec est un temps de concentration
et un truc 1 2 3
c'est ce qui a trait à 13 alors et j'ai
pas dit mais c'est de le perdre on ya un
cadeau pour lui aussi pour le grand
perdant à coulx 3 2 un jeu non plus à
temps cela fera le papa papa papa papa
regarde jouer la gagne c'est la perçois
faire fois qu'on joue à ce jeu là des
cadeaux on et diallo pour le perdant
pour sanctionner sympa je suis en mesure
de tenir bon quoi ce brume c'est le cas
de max sait trop ce qu'il avait qualifié
de très chaud
[Musique]
c'est un gag très ancien il ya plutôt
mal vieilli d'ailleurs était pas si
rigolo c'est pas le meilleur moment de
la vidéo est interdit au calme les gars
c'est un jeu vraiment je vois ça j'ai eu
quelques logos j'aime pas ça on va tous
maintenant non l'électricité non mais
c'est quoi ces justes tout devait
exécuter
ouais c'est grâce à la toile c'est
aléatoire c'est à la doua je déteste
chacun chacun doigt dedans allez allez
allez on dû tout faire ça puisse y
incarne maintenant atteinte à deux
secondes je te jure
maliweb ckoi mentalement faut y aller
faut pas se laisser aller à ce poste là
c'est très dur à tuer si je suis prêt la
cayolle papier sur start pertes
vous allez juste appuyer écoutez moi
bien
c'est l'objet le plus terrifiant tu es
jeune tu vas vis et les gars finit pas
d'affoler vas-y à faire ça
aussi génial passer une roue
à
[Musique]
je suis coupé court rien de ce moment je
suis trop bien
déjà je me suis pris la décharge mais
après on entend bien merci se casse et
je me jette dessus
regardez ça regardez maintenant c'est
moi qui adore les canaux pour la face à
la caméra
tout le monde sait ce que c'est qu'est
ce que c'est bon au jeu tom cruise merci
à tous abonnez vous
[Musique]